I think I only go to 7-eleven on road
trips they've got these little brownie
cookie things that are real good pretty
good food I feel like Japanese people
just really know how to like up the ante
yeah well they're vending machines are
like really cool over there I'm sure
they'll like make 7-eleven amazing Oh
[Music]
what is this green chip there's a nice
dust on here I love the dust you can't
see the dust but there's a great does I
love to sit down just a bag of these and
I'm gonna movie mm40 a chips kind of
like tastes like you need to have like
some sort of dip but these edamame chips
I could just see a whole bag on his own
honestly any sort of like wrapped baked
good it's always good oh yeah it's a
smoothest doughnut I've ever holy [ __ ]
this doughnut is lubed up I didn't say
it was looting mmm hollow much drier
than I thought it would be
it's like cardboard this was either made
in 30 seconds very hastily or was made
90 years ago I'm not really sure which
one it is sugar butter Sandri well this
is great from the get-go because it
looks like something I haven't had oh my
god that's not delight
what we work really hard to burn
mouthfeel was not great now feels not
great but then that frosting starts to
mix with the tree bark part of it it
turns into this wonderful little
cacophony of sweetness what we got a
look oh oh we got scabs Oh plum plum oh
my god old a you people love oh man it
changes it's always a buffing my mouth
this is great this is a symphony of
flavor I like it by eight to finish
every time it's so sour that is the most
sour thing I've ever had my life this
looks like it was made in five seconds
there are literally raisins in there
it's not just like a raisin flavoured
thing there's literally just little
raisins in it is this like a Japanese
ants on a log
is there alcohol in this oh this is how
kids learn to drink you just feed them
one of these rum breeze and sandwiches
and you're good to go
I didn't feel like we've got the best of
Japan overall I thought there was a wide
variety of things here I'm very
impressed with like Japanese 7/11 I'm
gonna call all sandwiches sand now
because that's how the cool kids in
Japan do it yeah who needs which when
you can just say saying hey let's get
some turkey fat yeah all about that sand
light
[Music]